jacques vergès vous publiez un bouquin
qui s'appelle je défends barbie et qui
reprend votre plaidoirie du procès
barbie à lyon et avec une très belle
préface de jean edern hallier d'ailleurs
qui se montre beaucoup plus sérieux qui
peut l'être d'habitude dans cette
préface dans la première question c'est
d'abord pourquoi dans les dossiers
complets qui ont été publiés par le
monde parle afp par globe
il n'y a pas eu disons tout ou partie de
votre plaidoirie qu'il faut attendre ce
livre pour la pour la connaître
le mac dry et dérangeante oui le procès
de lions et d'un spectacle et le
l'accusé n'est pas un homme c'est
inspectent c'est une image ce qu'une
silhouette
or moi j'ai introduit dans ce débat la
dimension humaine et par conséquent je
dérange
or ce procès a duré de bois ils étaient
préparés par trois en deux
comment t'es tu es ma plaidoirie mettant
en cause
c'est de ces trois ans et deux mois de
plus je dirais veut
de lavage de cerveau alors pris cet
éditeur jean picollec parce que vous
avez vraiment est ce que vous avez eu
des refus de d'autres éditeurs est ce
que vous l'avez un peu ma portée je sais
pas où seul j'ai grasset chez plon chez
fayard finalement vous êtes vous
réfugier chez jean picollec
je vous dirais que ma plaidoirie ans
après le procès et personne n'est pas
facile alors que vous aviez des requins
et des plaidoiries
il ya eu des recueils publiés la
personne m'a fait c est plus je ne peux
pas les nommer parce qu'ils ont des
excuses
les éditeurs quelques éditeurs je
connais auxquels je me suis adressé ont
invoqué la dureté des contenus la
difficulté est de passer et si bien que
c'est monsieur picollec qui a passé
lui en est de la critique mais c'est qui
ce jean picollec jean picollec est
actuellement le
je ne sais pas quel est le titre in sa
part le directeur de la table ronde
avant donc c'est sous son propre nom
qu'il put mais il avait avant d'être à
la table ronde
occuper ce poste qu'il avait sa propre
maison d'édition vous a comparé à
faurisson ça aller jusque là vous pensez
quoi les travaux de faurisson
je vous dirais que j'ai été volontaire
dans les forces françaises d ouais j'ai
fait la guerre de
j'avais 17 ans quand bien même temps
depuis cette période je me suis caire je
ne suis pas un ancien combattant
je me suis pas occupé beaucoup de cette
période ça vous empêche pas de réfléchir
sur ce qu'il a fait est absolument
et non ce n'est pas pour éviter les
choses pour vous dire que c'est un
produit de profaner un sujet pour moi la
vérité que tout le monde affirme ne
pouvoir est la vérité
et on ne peut pas trouver dans ma
plaidoirie un seul argument
révisionnisme et si un jour faurisson
est attaqué et qui vous demande de
défendre ce que vous le soir je défends
par principe tout ceux qui sont attaqués
maintenant ça dépend pour dire quoi
efforts en tant qu il ya un accord entre
mon client et moi je vous dirais que
d'une manière générale je ne comprends
pas qu'on attaque quelques si quelqu'un
soutient des thèses absurde qu'on les
réfute et qu'on le ridicule et mais
l'intérêt des français que c'est plutôt
de la sorcellerie mais l'intervention du
bras séculier me semble absolument
unique
vous avez eu un avatar et quelques jours
dans l'école normale rue d'ulm vous êtes
allé faire une conférence sur la beauté
du crime
et puis c'est un peu mal terminée on
vous acheter des oeufs alors d'abord
pourquoi pourquoi la vanille du crime là
et deuxièmement pourquoi les yeux alors
là il faut d'abord qu'ils l'union de
l'histoire des jeux qui est un détail le
les associations des élèves de l'école
normale supérieur m'avait invité et
j'avais accepté avec comme thème de ma
causerie le botté ducret il ya eu un
incident que la presse a mal rapporté
trois individus qui de toute évidence à
leur physique n'a pas retenu par l'école
oui je pense même qu'il n'avait pas dû
dépasser le scientifique a dit qu il
avait le front est roi il comprenait
rien à ce que je dis c'est qu'il était
nerveux donc ces trois primitif à un
moment où non je parlais du dr faust
excédés se sont levés et moi j'aime on
peut observer leur manège ils ont ils
sont sortis et sur le côté ils m'ont
bombardé avec des oeufs puis quand on
est bombardé avec the et qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude surtout quand les hommes sur
les lunettes d'abord on est aveugle
et puis deuxième on se demande ce que
ces lieux rapidement à la pression de
glu qui est que j'avais sur les jours
j'avais compris que c'était pas quelque
chose de très grave
et puis ses chances se sont enfuis donc
ça n'a aucun rapport et écoles et
juste après j'ai continué ma causerie
pourquoi la beauté du crime parce que
mais là c'est insu à notre sujet
monsieur j mentale me faire les
conférences comme ça mais en euros en
gros je pense que c'est celle de près le
crime c'est ce qui distingue la société
humaine de la société animale dans la
société anima n'y a pas d'infraction
dans la ruche label ouvrière à butiner
jusqu'à sa mort
la reine va pondre jusqu'à sa mort et
cela depuis des millions d'années cela
pour continuer encore des millions
d'années justin catastrophe qui mettra
fin au règne des abeilles l'ouvrière ne
pensera jamais qu'elle peut faire grève
ni la reine qu'elle peut se faire
avorter et séchez-les bande chez les
hommes et depuis que nous avons quitté
ce n'est pas marxiste forcément ces
chrétiens depuis que nous avons goûté au
fruit de la connaissance que
l'attraction caractérise la société
humaine et c'est ce qui fait la société
humaine départ répétitives qu'elle
devient c'est ce qui fait qu'il ya une
histoire sur le plan collectif et sur le
plan individuel un destin vous avez des
causes très célèbre bien sûr ça a
commencé avec le cnf djamila bouhired
lui boulin il ya eu la salle à
simone weber est urgent ibrahim abdallah
et barbie quel a été pour vous la cause
la plus délicate à défendre celle qui
vous a demandé le plus de travail
d'énergie de tentatives de persuasion
puisque finalement c'est notre boulot je
dirais que toutes ces causes me
passionne j'ai prêté au cours de l'année
dernière la sphère abdallah en février
la sphère barbe et andé j'étais désigné
par madame webber en septembre je suis
passé de ballereau merten salomon toute
fin de salomon à mauriac ou à maigret
tous toutes ces associations
passionnante des celle qui vous a
demandé le plus de revenus la plus
délicate la plus délicate si vous voulez
le plus de travail plus de boulot le
plus de travail c'est la sphère barbie
incontestablement parce que vous savez
que l'avocat en france n'a pas les mêmes
moyens et que l'accusation au procès
j'étais seule la plupart du temps jeu
sauf à la fin lorsqu'un ami africain et
algériennes et algériens sont venus à
mes côtés mais sur les huit semaines du
procès j'ai été cette semaine seul en
face de 39 confrères et tu procureur à
dire que la déco c'est ce que vous
pensez que vous êtes le plus grand des
avocats de france où
je ne peux pas penser que je suis le
plus grand parce qu'à mon avis
ne pas dire grand chose disons que
c'est vrai que je m'occupe des affaires
que j'estime mois les plus intéressants
les plus signifiants de notre temps vous
avez des contacts avec le fln caisse non
vous en pas encore demandé
tabourets prendre là dessus oui non et
non seulement devant vous demander non
je n'en sais strictement rien bien sûr
que j'accepte en général toutes les
causes difficiles
pensez quoi des situations nouvelle
calédonie parce que c'est pas l'algérie
quand même il ya autant d des kanaks et
caldoches pu se métisse quoi je veux
dire c'est pas c'est pas une situation
on la rapproche souvent l'algérie mais
c'est pas exactement la même chose n'ont
jamais vu situation ne ressemble à une
autre ou totalement
si vous voulez
et ceci est une peu sur le ton de la
confidence je suis né d'une mère
italienne et d'un père d'origine
française de l'île de la réunion
j'ai vécu mon père a été viré du
consulat de france en thaïlande a valu
ma naissance que j'ai vécu à l'île de la
réunion jusqu'à ce que je m'engage chez
de gaulle
j'ai conservé de cet enfant si des
formes attira
une très grande sensibilité à la
situation coloniale
en même temps c'est ce qui fait
peut-être la dualité de ma personne
c'est je suis de culture française
incontestablement et c'est une culture
non seulement que je respecte mais que
j'aime beaucoup il ya quel je suis
attaché dès
et je dirais que ce rang ce qui concerne
les kanaks
je suis très ému comme en ce qui
concerne les aborigènes d'australie de
voir des populations qui sont là depuis
des millénaires
fin 2000 entre bilan des six mille ans
la mi temps mais elle a su de migration
qu'on ne connaît pas très bien qui sont
sur cette terre ancestrale dont les
mines sont centrées autour de la terre
pensait que d'un coup menacés dans leur
terre et leurs pieds et leurs existences
ça me touche profondément vous pensé
quand même que
globalement la canaille qui devrait être
kanak et qu'est ce qu'on ferait des
caldoches alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
tous ces gens là ont créé comme
l'algérie on les envie de prendre un
bateau pour marseille ça se passerait
comme ans je ne vois pas du tout ce je
ne suis pas politique
cdg des opinions mais je veux dire que
je suis la politique je ne suis pas dans
membre d'un parti je ne m'attache pas à
des solutions immédiates de certains
problèmes
je pense que même en algérie
si on avait négocié à temps les gens
auraient pu rester les gens de réussir
mort du respect mais comment se fait-il
que vous n'ayez jamais eu envie enfin je
sais que votre frère paul député
communiste de la réunion mais il est
quand même député la république
française comment se fait-il que vous
ayez jamais eu envie de prendre la tête
du front de libération national de la
réunion parce que finalement toute votre
vie d'avocat a été une lutte perpétuelle
finalement tant que colonialisme et même
votre plaidoirie dans le procès vergès
se fonde sur des guerres coloniales pas
sur les atrocités commises dans les
gares de france fait partie d'un procès
barbie
bien sûr et comment se fait-il que vous
ayez jamais eu envie de
parce que pour l'indépendance de la
réunion après tout c'est pas ce pays je
vous dirais que j'exerce une profession
qui est pour moi
enfin combat bien compact et obéit
l'arrêt des règles et s'est du même coup
un jeu
je passe dedans et que je vis comme une
passion aussi et que je vis après ce que
je vous ai dit sur la beauté du crime
comme également une création c
ne demandez pas à atteindre même s'il a
des opinions politiques de se présenter
comme candidat dans les deux scènes voc
avait été très proche du parti
communiste même membre du parti
communiste
quand vous voyez là
l'urss quitter l'afghanistan ça vous
fait quoi que ça peut poser se fait
désirer
donc vous pensez que le fait que les
afghans n'est pas supporté qu'on leur
impose un régime communiste finalement
c'est une bonne chose
je pense
que les gens ont à faire leur destin eux
mêmes et qu'on n'a pas à leur imposer de
l'extérieur une solution donc vous
pensez que les vietnamiens devrait
quitter le combattue par exemple c'est
la hausse absolument
alors pour en revenir à problèmes
question qu'on vous pose à chaque fois
qu'on vous voit votre fameuse absence
alors jean edern hallier dit dans sa
plaidoirie vie entre 70 et 78 jacques
vergès a disparu moi je sais où ils
étaient ils étaient dans les maquis
bolivien je les ai vus dans un bordel à
tel aviv je les ai vus chez les khmers
rouges
vous ne direz pas ce soir où vous étiez
pendant ses huit ans vous avez dit que
vous étiez passé de l'autre côté du
miroir
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas devenu
combattant pendant sept ans
je vous dirais que ce que dis-je dans
les derniers doit être pris au deuxième
degré c'est la présence dans un bordel à
tel aviv ray est vraiment avec l'un
d'eux j'ai dit que j'étais passé de
l'autre côté du miroir parce que c'est
vrai que je suis revenu de cette absence
non pas différent mais mûri changé
je dirais beaucoup plus assurer vos
coupes luca avaient révélé lloris et
cela aguerri sur hautement spirituelle
il était devenu combattant
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle le monde
attendait qu'un fusil non je sais quoi
votre prochaine
prochaine cause
prochaine cause je vais plaider le 15
juin à aix pour une dizaine ou une
quinzaine de jours
dans la sphère de l'assassinât du juge à
quelques semaines de la défense que je
j'estime que le rôle de l'avocat n'est
pas d'être du côté de l'accusation
c
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu